[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the evolution of Spider-Man in
all his movie and TV series appearances
from 1977 to 2024. if you liked the
video be sure to leave us a like And
subscribe to the channel to not miss out
on any future content regarding your
favorite movies without further Ado
let's get started
The Amazing Spider-Man is a 1977
superhero movie that premiered on CBS
and was launched theatrically in other
regions eat have you swackham or
directed the movie which is written by
Alvin boritz and featured Nicholas
Hammond as the main protagonist it is
Columbia picture's first Spider-Man
motion picture it is based on the story
of Peter Parker who was performed by
Nicholas Hammond who is a freelance
journalist for the Daily Bugle and is
stung by an irradiated spider and learns
his acquired superhuman Powers such as
remarkable strength flexibility and the
skill to move up roofs and walls when a
shadowy guru uses psychic powers to rob
banks Peter converts into the dress
protagonist Spider-Man to thwart the
Crook's evil agenda the guru then
proclaims that he will brainwash 10
citizens at random into attempting
suicide except if the public pays him 50
million dollars culminating The Daily
Bugle header are you one of the 10
people the risk increases when Peter
Parker and His companion Judy are caught
by the guru's men and intrigued into
becoming two of the people who would
also jump from the Empire State Building
with Fortune Peter is able to break away
from the trance
Spider-Man Strikes Back as a 1978 sequel
to The Amazing Spider-Man the 1977
superhero movie it was directed and
written by Ron satloff and it stars
Nicholas Hammond as the main protagonist
Peter Parker's peers procure pretty
unstable nuclear materials which are
vital aspects of the invention of an
atomic bomb as the cops highly doubt
Parker of the robbery and Spider-Man
pursues Gail Hoffman an inquisitive
journalist is Keen to consult the city's
disguised guard meanwhile Mr White the
brutal businessman and Crime Boss is
hell-bent on attempting to steal the
plutonium required to build a tragic
nuclear weapon the crazed villain is now
threatening to destroy the Trade Center
Spider-Man the dragon's challenge is a
superhero movie that debuted in theaters
on May 9 1981 Don McDougall directed the
movie which was authored by Lionel e
Siegel and featured Nicholas Hammond as
the main protagonist it's the follow-up
to Spider-Man 1977 and Spider-Man
Strikes Back 1978 minlo Chan the Chinese
minister of industrial growth and a
former classmate of J Jonah Jameson runs
away to Hong Kong to pursue assistance
from the United States after becoming
wrongfully charged with treason and
spying during World War II to help
improve his innocence Jameson appoints
the help in support of Peter Parker
ignorant of the fact that the
unprincipled and risky business person
zeider is inclined to use powerful
strategies to guarantee his firm obtains
a multi-billion dollar agreement with
China
Spider-Man the Animated Series is an
American superhero cartoon television
show predicated on the popular Marvel
Comics Action Hero from November 19th
1994 to January 31st 1998. the show
premiered on the fox kids network for
Five Seasons and 65 episodes Marvel
films animation developed the TV show
which was reimagined by Tokyo movie
shinsha the show revolves around the
life of the friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man who lives up in this cult
favorite bringing legendary storylines
such as the Symbiote Saga and Secret
Wars to life
Saban entertainment Spider-Man Unlimited
is an animated series based on the
Marvel comic book character Spider-Man
Unlimited made its debut in 1999 but it
was completely overshadowed by Pokemon
and the newly launched Digimon and was
canceled only after a few episodes box
kids later broadcasted the TV series
again from 2000 to 2001 airing 13
episodes the final of which concluded on
a cliffhanger
Spider-Man is the superhero movie
centered on the same name Marvel Comics
hero is the first chapter in the story
in raimi's Spider-Man trilogy directed
by Sam Raimi from an original screenplay
by David Capp and featuring Toby Maguire
as the main protagonist the movie
depicts the backstory of Spider-Man and
his initial superhero career in life
after becoming bitten by a genetically
manipulated spider introvert teenager
Peter Parker acquires spider-like
superhuman powers and Embraces a
disguised personality to prevent crimes
and oppression in New York City within
which he comes into contact with the
villainous Green Goblet
another television show adaptation
Spider-Man the new animated series was
developed by Mainframe entertainment for
Sony Pictures Television and televised
on MTV in 2003 it showcased protagonists
and was consistent with the 2002
Spider-Man movie as well as Michael
Clark Duncan bringing back his role as
the Kingpin from the 2003 Daredevil
movie version the TV series only seemed
to last one season which comprised 13
episodes Neil Patrick Harris recorded
the voice of Spider-Man
Spider-Man 2 is the second edition of
raymie's Spider-Man series and the
spin-off to Spider-Man 2002 featuring
Toby Maguire Kirsten Dunst and James
Franco it is premised on the completely
fictitious Marvel comic superhero of the
same name set two years following the
occurrences of Spider-Man the film
uncovers Peter Parker trying to battle
Dr octo Octavius to avert him from
revisiting the destructive testing that
caused his wife's death and left him
biologically complexed to robotic
tendrils while also trying to deal with
an identity crisis between his twin
personalities that seemed to be
swindling him of his capabilities
raymie's Spider-Man trilogy concludes
with Spider-Man 3 Tobey Maguire plays
Peter Parker in the film Cliff Robertson
renders his final movie appearance
before stepping down and passing away in
2011. the movie is slated within a year
of the happenings of Spider-Man 2 and
pursues Peter Parker as he gears up for
his coming years with Mary Jane while
confronted with new villains like
Sandman Harry Osborne and Eddie Brock
Peter also confronts his greatest
challenge when he pairs with an
interplanetary symbiote which enhances
his skills and abilities while
exacerbating his anguish and other
negative behaviors
The Amazing Spider-Man is an action hero
film about the Marvel comic book
character Spider-Man bearing the same
name as the character's lengthiest comic
book series it is the fourth cinematic
Spider-Man movie directed by Columbia
Pictures and Marvel entertainment and
the debut of two of The Amazing
Spider-Man movies it is a relaunch of
the series that follows Sam raimi's
2002-2007 Spider-Man trilogy Mark Webb
produced the film and featured Andrew
Garfield as Peter Parker after being
bitten by a genetically manipulated
spider Parker gains innate spider-like
powers and sets out to safeguard the
city from the lizard's ploys
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 rise of Electro
also known as The Amazing Spider-Man 2
is a superhero movie based on the Marvel
superhero Spider-Man Mark Webb created
the film which was developed by Avi arid
and Matt tolmac it is the fifth and last
cinematic Spider-Man movie made by
Columbia Pictures and Marvel
entertainment the spin-off to The
Amazing Spider-Man 2012 and the final
episode in The Amazing Spider-Man series
Andrew Garfield performs Peter Parker
who attempts to safeguard Gwen Stacy
while exploring his parents deaths as
well as engaging with the new villain
Electro and the return of his lifelong
friend Harry Osborne who is facing death
due to a fatal genetic disorder
Spider-Man homecoming is a 2017 American
superhero movie co-produced by Columbia
Pictures and Marvel Studios and released
by Sony Pictures it is based on the
Marvel Comics character Spider-Man it is
the second spin-off of Spider-Man and
the 16th movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe MCU Tom Holland performs Peter
Parker who is facing issues in high
school and also being Spider-Man whilst
also facing the vulture Spider-Man far
from home 2019 and Spider-Man no way
home 2021 are the two sequels Sony and
Marvel Studios are developing a brand
new live-action movie series
Spider-Man into the spider-verse is a
computer animated action hero film
starring Miles Morales as Spider-Man
from Marvel Comics Columbia Pictures and
Sony pictures animation produced it in
collaborative efforts with Marvel
entertainment is the first cartoon
Spider-Man movie as well as the only
first to Showcase a black Spider-Man it
features to make more as Morales and is
directed by Bob persiketti Peter Ramsey
and Rodney Rothman from a film script by
Phil Lord and Rothman the story of the
film pursues Miles Morales as he
transforms into the new Spider-Man and
collaborates with other spider people
from distinct multiple worlds to redeem
his world from Kingpin
Spider-Man far from home is a movie
premised on the Marvel comic superhero
Spider-Man that was co-produced by
Columbia Pictures and Marvel Studios and
launched by Sony Pictures releasing it
is the 23rd movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the spin-off to
Spider-Man homecoming 2017. John Watts
directed the movie which was written by
Chris McKenna and Eric Summers and
wanted him to star Tom Holland as Peter
Parker Parker is enlisted by Nick Fury
and Mysterio to confront the Elementals
during an educational trip to Europe in
the movie
Spider-Man no way home is a superhero
film based on the comics character
Spider-Man it was co-produced by
Columbia Pictures and Marvel Studios and
it was launched by Sony Pictures
releasing it is the 27th movie in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
spin-off to Spider-Man homecoming 2017
and Spider-Man far from home 2019. John
Watts produced the film which was
authored by Chris McKenna and Eric
Summers it features Tom Holland as Peter
Parker who requests Dr Steven strange to
use Wizardry to keep his identity hidden
as Spider-Man after it was disclosed at
the end of far from home when the
enchantment screws up the Multiverse
comes crashing down allowing foreign
tourists from other Realms to access
Parker's world
Spider-Man across the spider-verse is a
forthcoming computer animated comic book
hero movie featuring Miles Morales from
Marvel Comics Columbia Pictures and Sony
pictures animation are developing it in
collaborative efforts with Marvel it is
a follow-up to Spider-Man into the
spider-verse 2018 and is established in
a collective Multiverse of different
realities known as the spider-verse it
is spread by Sony Pictures releasing
should make more performs miles who set
sail on a Multiverse Journey with a new
Squad of spider people
Spider-Man freshman year is a
forthcoming animated American Web
television show focused on the same name
Marvel Comics hero it is the 27th
television show in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the third cartoon series
Marvel Studios is developing the
sequence which will be accessible on
Disney plus the cartoon show follows
Peter Parker on his path towards
becoming Spider-Man in the MCU with an
unparalleled adventure and an aesthetic
that refers to the character's initial
comic book Heritage Spider-Man's
sophomore year a spin-off sequence is
also in the works
that's it for today what is your
favorite Spider-Man movie or TV show
during the years and what are your
expectations of the upcoming Spider-Man
across the spider-verse movie let us
know in the comments down below be sure
to leave us a like if you enjoyed the
video and subscribe for more content on
the biggest upcoming Blockbusters until
next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]